well Christianity's transitive does
answer all my questions I mean it's it's
its little lens through which I view
reality it's how I make judgments it's
how I respond to others
it's how I define reality to all intents
and purposes the Christian myth makes
sense to me it provides a world as
orderly and stable to me as though as
the Greek myths did for the Greeks and
the Romans did for the Romans I I don't
live in a dark world I mean I don't I
don't live in the sense that everything
is gonna go up in flames and we're all
destined and doomed and terrible things
are happening happening but I do believe
we live in what the Scriptures referred
to as a fallen world Christian theology
speaks of it as a world that has not
achieved its ideals and we are
struggling and moving towards them
trying to manage as best we can and
certain ideals and ideas have been set
before us the person of Jesus Christ for
me is such an idea and an ideal I
believe he really existed but that
doesn't diminish the ideological power
or the the sense of imagination that is
employed and I aspire to live my life in
the light of what I understand that
truth to be a truth which I have
received through the wisdom of thousands
of other smarter and cleverer people who
existed before me I admit to being a
child of the Western Christian
experience and I embrace it I I'm not
ashamed of it I'm not embarrassed by it
and I don't deny my dependency upon it
it's the vocabulary with which I work
when I traveled as I often do through
Western Europe and I look at those great
cathedrals and those monuments they all
speak to me they all make sense to me
it's describing a world in which I did
not live but which still lives for me
and that's
very important part of my work I suppose
it's trying to call back as best I can
the life of that world to people who are
far removed from it
I'm much comforted by the remark GK
Chesterton once said that Christianity
is not a religion that has been tried
and failed it's a religion that has been
wanted and never really tried and my job
is to try it and get other people to try
it on for size and hope for the best